je me trouve à drocourt un petit village
situé au nord des yvelines avec 343
habitants ici au second tour de la
présidentielle il y a eu 50 % pour
emmanuel macron et 50% pour marine le
pen nous allons aller à la rencontre des
habitants et bon moi je suis pas déçu
avec les promesses qu'il a fait monsieur
vaincrons je parlais avec une copine
pour les retraites et tout ça c'est pas
très décevant
moi j'ai voté pour le pen le vannes oc
moi j'aurais pensé que le pen y aurait
passé avant et macro et les touches qui
dit et c'est pas c'est pas toujours vrai
mais ça m'étonne je suis pas vraiment
surprise des résultats peut-être même
que je pensais que le pen passerait
davantage puisque elle avait fait un
meilleur score que mâcon au premier tour
voilà après ce que je pense des
résultats pas forcément hyper satisfait
de voilages et si voter pour ce qui me
semble être le mieux
j'ai pas voté pour une conviction
absolue
sur la personne qui ce qui se fait de
personnes qui se présentaient voilà
après on verra bien ce que ça donnera
j'espère que monsieur macron
on aura pris note c'est ce qu'il a dit
hier maintenant je crois qu'on attend
beaucoup pour lui quoi je suis
actuellement avec le maire de drocourt
dominique pierré bonjour bonjour alors
dans votre village il ya eu 50 % de voix
pour emmanuel macron et 50% de voix pour
marine le pen comment est-ce que ça vous
surprend
non ça ne surprend pas disons que
effectivement
si vous voulez on n'est pas loin de la
commune de mantes la jolie j'ai fait
quand même donc 24 logements sociaux sur
la commune et je me souviens très bien
quand on a fait donc que ces logements
eh bien on est on avait des réactions où
les gens avaient un petit peu peur
qu'est ce que l'on veut avoir comme
population et c'est donc à la proximité
de mantes la jolie qui est quand même
dans toutes les têtes des trous courtois
vous l'aurez compris malgré cette
égalité parfaite entre les deux
candidats au second tour de la
présidentielle les drocourtois et les
drocourtoise attendent beaucoup du
second quinquennat d'emmanuel vaincrons